l'autre transition qui est absolument
majeur c'est la transition numérique où
la france a pris un retard considérable
et là aussi il faut investir dans la
robotisation et la numérisation de notre
système économique pour reprendre des
parts de marché pour reconstruire un
système productif efficace je donne
juste un chiffre malheureusement vous
prenez les pme les oatei française vous
en avez encore 35 % quand même pas de
site internet crédible alors que le
chiffre comparable en allemagne et 15%
donc là il ya des initiatives alors la
bpi a déjà pris des initiatives
mais il faut aller beaucoup plus loin et
je termine par là aussi une proposition
on va avoir une année scolaire enfin les
diplômés de 2019 et peut-être même ceux
de 2020 vont avoir du mal à trouver du
boulot mais moi je proposerai une
initiative temporaire qui pourrait durer
deux ou trois ans où le l'état en lien
avec les régions et les départements
proposent un emploi d'un an aux jeunes
diplômés pour les mettre dans les
entreprises pour aider les entrepreneurs
à numériser leur boîte
les jeunes recevant une formation de
deux trois mois puis ensuite on les
envoie dans les entreprises les jeunes
sont très très bon dans toutes les
questions du mérite et ça leur mettrait
le pied à l'étrier
donc il ya une initiative absolument
majeur qui permettrait là aussi de
traiter l'énorme problème d'emploi des
jeunes qu'on va se prendre en plein dans
la figure sur les deux années qui
viennent et qui permettrait d'agir sur
la robotique sur la robotisation
numérisation de notre système productif
[Musique]